this is a family show
or is it
four is it
Harry Styles rips his pants mid-c
concert all in front of his childhood
Crush Jennifer Aniston stay excited and
possibly something will happen
the singer's wardrobe malfunction
happened at his Los Angeles show while
performing his song music for a sushi
restaurant at one point Harry drops a
knee and tears his brown leather pants
wide open at the crotch awkward this is
a family show
or is it
to add to the embarrassment Harry had
some A-list fans in the crowd including
Modern Family star Julie Bowen
tonight's the night and I upgraded
I'm here and I know what I'm doing and
Julie excitedly revealed that Jennifer
Aniston and Ellen DeGeneres were at the
show too oh my God guys Ellen DeGeneres
is here and so is Jennifer Anakin so why
am I down here
[Music]
thank you
oh yeah Jen's totally jamming out to
Harry's song as it was so she may have
been witness to his unexpected Moment On
Stage this is a family show or is it
and it turns out the friend star holds a
special place in Harry's heart who was
your first celebrity crush
really Jennifer Aniston
I think well Harry moved along with this
concert like a pro necessary to
apologize
I mean this is a
you have to kind of think about what's
what's more important and we're sure
Julie didn't mind that wardrobe mishap
at all the actress is a big hairy Stan
just bringing the joy and the light and
the watermelon sugar
you just feel good about the whole
experience oh and Julia revealed to her
Modern Family co-star Adam DeVine that
she would totally date the pop star word
on the street is you got a little bit of
a crush girl
okay I see what I see where this guy
this kid's coming after me being retired
you're asking when I come out of
retirement first for yeah dating
retirement oh hell yeah uh-huh oh him
look at him
look at him yeah
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]